Here's another algebraic way
of thinking about this, okay?
Using our old definition
of b transpose b, okay,
you'll notice that what it is
is actually this matrix okay?
Sum of x squared, sum of xys,
sum of xys, sum of y squared.
Well that's just the covariance matrix
of the points assuming that
there are about the origin.
So I don't have to track that the mean,
that would be the covariance.
Speaking of which, yet one more
way of thinking about this is that
B transpose B here is
the sum of this xx transpose.
That's what's referred
to as the outer product.
And if it's about the origin, I don't
have to subtract off the mean, but
the, here it is written just like that.
That again is the definition
of the covariance matrix.
This makes some sense, for those of you
thinking about it, the covariance matrix
is a relationship between
the expected value of the squares,
the sum of the squares of points
distributed about the mean.
So that's actually,
if you think about it,
the saying what we wanted to, to know.
We wanted to know the greatest variance.
For those of you that care, or
are thinking about, if you think about
a covariance matrix as an ellipsoid in
space your eigenvectors are going to be,
end up being,
the major axis of these ellipsoids.